today I'm going to talk about a problem
we have that Airbnb this isn't a problem
unique to Airbnb actually many wouldn't
even consider it a problem but instead
just the way things are and always have
them and the problem I'm talking about
is that at every MV we write we write
every V three times every feature we add
to Airbnb needs to get created for at
least three different platforms web
Android and iOS for each of these
platforms we rate hundreds of thousands
or even millions of lines of code to
build out the features that make up
Airbnb although in each platform the
result of the code is largely the same
it's not actually the same code each
platform has its own set of frameworks
and languages that separate them weave
JavaScript and react on the web Java and
Android and Swift on iOS we write all
this functionality separately for each
platform each feature is likely
implemented by a different and engineer
specialist for that one platform this
means that each engineer implementing it
must go through the same process of
gaining context on the nuance of that
actual feature and this means that each
implementation will likely have its own
set of bugs and corner cases that were
missed on the first pass and every move
we've recently started adopting react
native for a development of some of the
features on our native apps so the
result is that for these features we
write the core functionality in the
language of JavaScript and react sharing
almost all of the code between iOS and
Android so for these features we
effectively move from writing Airbnb
three times to writing it two times
so this says we see that we're in a
fundamentally different situation than
before it's a language and framework
level we actually have some similarities
it's now feasible for us to have the
same engineer skilled in JavaScript and
react right the feature for all three
platforms once for web and then once for
react native targeting iOS and
enjoyed the interesting thing about this
is that for that individual engineer
this can actually be a more frustrating
situation than before even though we're
effectively writing it two times instead
of three it might be the same engineer
doing it and now that engineer has to
feel the pain and agony of almost
identical code since they're now writing
it in both cases so if you're in this
situation the engineer in you might take
a step back and try to figure out how to
share this code if we can somehow figure
out how to get react web and react
native code to work together we can get
into this ideal world of writing Airbnb
just once for the three major platforms
that we want to support so it turns out
this is much easier said than done react
web and react native are not easily
compatible and I'll go into a bit more
about why later in this talk but I want
to talk about a way that we can make
react not just support these three
platforms but any platform I mean I
don't know what if we could write it
once run it anywhere
okay so there's a bit of a stigma around
this contest the idea of cross-platform
UI is not new and there are a number of
failures mr. mature solutions out there
that do this but these attempts have
often fallen short and have burned
really any chance of receiving a good
first impression so much so that the
react community itself for years now is
actually actually actively said no we're
not trying to do this we're not trying
to write once run anywhere and at this
point there might be some of you
listening to me now
and then feeling a bit like this
cross-platform UI is a pipe dream why
are we talking about it but it always
resolved in subpar experiences and non
idiomatic code
and there might be another section of
you that are feeling a little bit like
this
you've been waiting for someone today
exactly this and you're ready to drink
that kool-aid as soon as it's served you
honestly regardless of which side of the
spectrum you're on I encourage you to
give it some thought before jumping to
any conclusions there is no perfect
solution but today I'd like to explain
you the way I think about cross platform
react and how I believe react has a real
shot to be different first I want you to
consider the fact that for the most part
the code we wrote for these three
platforms was separate not because they
were separate concerns but because we
were forced to write multiple
implementations by the technology that
was available to us separate current
concerns should be separate by using a
single language and framework we've made
sharing code extremely easy but now you
can draw the boundaries wherever it
makes sense not where the technology
forces you to so consider for a moment a
world where every platform had one
paradigm for creating UI and one
ecosystem of mature cross-platform
libraries components frameworks and best
practices and ultimately the goal is for
codes to be portable portable between
any platform code that needs to be
optimized for a specific platform or
things that require platform specific
implementation can be easily accounted
for we don't want to have to write one
single code path for all platforms or
develop for the least common denominator
we want to share code that it's the same
easily and not share code that needs to
be different so it sounds great how do
we get there can we actually make a
reactive ecosystem work this way I think
we can but to understand how we react
fits into all this let's take a look
back in time at reactive history so
react started getting used at Facebook
and Instagram all the way back in 2011
in March 2013 it got open source - a
lukewarm reception react was so new and
different that the benefits weren't
understood at first over time the
reaction ad grew and grew and it's now
become one of the most active tech
communities that's ever existed and then
two years after
and the initial open-sourcing of react
react native with open sores this was a
huge shift for the whole community until
this moment virtual Dom was essentially
just a buzzword that people thought had
something to do with performance react
native woke people up to the fact that
react decouples building a UI from the
underlying platform react native took
advantage of this and utilized to react
paradigm for building UI on to new
platforms iOS and Android this really
opened people's eyes what other
platforms could be do this for this
ended up being exactly the catalyst that
was needed to get react on other
platforms later we saw a react native
web good open source which allows for
people to use react on the web with an
API identical to react native following
that was react native for Mac OS react
native for Windows react native for
boomtube and even react native for VR so
we see that reaction is already being
used to target as many as 8 different
platforms is react already
cross-platform sort of react certainly
can target a lot of platforms but none
of them are compatible with one another
to show you what I mean let's take a
look at this hypothetical react
component right now the only thing this
component depends on is react and react
doesn't really assume any platform so
it's cross-platform let's assume now
that you want to allow for multiple
children or you want to do some sort of
styling if you were using this in a
web-based environment you'd maybe wrap
the return value and it is give it a
class name react makes adding and
creating HTML elements extremely easy
but now in this moment we've lost all
platform compatibility div and class
name our web specific in reality we
should be thinking of any HTML elements
that we're using and react as an
implicit dependency on react on easy to
write HTML element and react really the
gateway drugs of react without them
moving from the pre react world to the
post react world would have been too big
of a shift the cost of that however is
most of the reactor ecosystem today is
implicitly dependent on react on so that
said the the situation with react native
and friends isn't actually any better as
soon as we want to do anything in this
component we end up having to take on an
explicit dependency to react Nate it
even though there may be other libraries
with almost identical interfaces without
a proper dependency injection system our
code has to choose one of the two so in
a nutshell cross-platform react needs to
solve this dependency problem we need to
agree on these kind of what the
fundamental components are and what they
do so let's give it a shot let's
standardize on a minimal interface or
set of API s that allow us to construct
meaningful you eyes and make sense
across all platforms I like to call
these primitives so where do we start
what are react primitives it turns out
Rag native has already done a lot of the
heavy lifting react needed was built for
both iOS and Android and to do that they
built a couple of really good
general-purpose primitives that had to
work well across the two platforms and
because of that they can also work well
on others as we saw in many libraries
and other platforms are popping up with
react native like interfaces too so this
is maybe a good place to start these are
all of the api's that react native
exports there's 73 in total that's a lot
of API s most of these API s are
somewhat specific to the mobile platform
and many don't many apps don't need them
at all for ecosystems that aren't react
native this is a huge API surface area
to keep track of and take on into
dependency one thing I noticed is when I
built out air VM use component library
for react native but I only end up using
a handful of these api's to create
virtually the entire library in fact I
only really ended up using these seven
these modules are the basis for what I
call the primitives the the fact that so
much of our code base can be expressed
by just a few of these API is really
interested
and I wanted to understand is other
people using react natives were yielding
similar results so I wrote a script that
tracked all of the react native imports
in a given codebase and had a number of
people using react native outside of
their B&B run it on their applications
based on this data it turns out that
together these seven api's account for
roughly 82 percent of all react native
usage in the wild there are a number of
other api's that react native exports
that could actually just be built
directly with these primitives they can
be thought of as just useful
compositions of these primitives and not
actual primitives in and of themselves
and then there are a handful of other
api's api is that i believe you actually
need to be implemented from scratch for
each platform but shouldn't quite be
considered primitives some of these are
straightforward implement and others
would not be but these are the modules
for which I believe a platform agnostic
third-party library could be made now if
you add all of these api's together that
accounts for roughly 96 percent of all
react native usage in the wild so with
this new knowledge the most practical
set of primitives that I could come up
with based on this were these seven API
view text image stylesheet touchable
animated and platform I've created an
NPM package called react primitives
which can serve as a recent pendency for
which a cross-platform react ecosystem
is built on view text and image are the
three core static UI components use the
core layout component used for basic
styling and for grouping and laying out
other components additionally we have
text for displaying text and image for
images style sheets the JavaScript API
to create style rules that other that
the other primitives understand and use
to style themselves a critical
requirement for you is to work
consistently is to have a consistent
layout algorithm
so in a way stylesheet can be thought of
as the public interface of the
underlying layout algorithm which in
this case is flexbox touchable is the
only primitive enabling user interaction
it's a react component that defines a
view that is pressable and optionally
drives animated values representing its
press state this does not directly
correspond to any of the touchable api's
that react native provides but all of
the react native touchable api's can be
implemented tribulation this animations
are a crucial crucial component for
pleasant user experiences and the
animated API pioneered by the react
native team does a great job making
animations declarative in order to
integrate really well which react and
then finally we have the platform API
platform is arguably a utility more than
it is a primitive and it allows us to
easily specify different logical
branches based on whichever platform
we're running on so a common question
about the choice of these primitives is
why you viewing text make better options
than the web equivalents didn't span the
react web community is much larger than
the react native community so why not
start with them as being the reason is
the div and spanner built for the web
and having other platforms implement
their complete interface is pretty much
equivalent to building an entire browser
the difference being of hundreds of
attributes that respect to allow for the
entire CSS spec as opposed to just a
subset of it if we choose to implement
just a subset there would be a lot of
really subtle things that that wouldn't
work view and text are more narrowly
scoped and have props that make more
sense with react component model so
assuming for a moment that we agree on
the interface that was just laid out
who's going to actually implement these
primitives for each platform where does
that code actually live so it turns out
that most of these targets have already
been made as we saw in going over react
history
many platforms have implemented this
interface or something really close to
it many of them live in separate repos
and have separate maintained errs and
that's okay this is essentially
dependency injection problem react
primitives is just the interface the
contract not the implementation react
firmness comes with an injection API
where you can configure it for whichever
target implementation you want based on
which environment that's running in this
is the added benefit of allowing
emerging platforms to use code built
from for more popular platforms with no
effort at all
there's no now no need to convince
maintainer zuv those projects that they
should care about a certain platform by
default react primitives will come with
a set of default injections for several
different targets well one can easily
override them with a different
implementation for a new platform so a
pretty valid question at this point is
whether or not these seven primitives
are actually the right permits for
example the animated API is a pretty
heavyweight dependency to be included as
a foundational primitive it's needed
currently to implement touchable in a
generic way but could potentially be
avoided
similarly scrollview is a pretty
foundational component that can't be
built from just the other primitives and
it's highly used so perhaps it should be
considered text inputs are an important
form of user interaction and they can't
be built from just the other primitives
so one problem with text input being a
primitive is that the text input varies
a lot by platform and some platforms
like for instance VR it might not even
apply as a concept and then finally with
gestures gestures are pretty interesting
to think about robust gesture systems
are needed to make things like touchable
and scroll view and animated work well
together and might be worth considering
as as a real primitive concept
unfortunately gesture systems are also
incredibly complicated and they're
implemented quite differently for
platform and on the web of a pretty
important platform no one has really
been
a good gesture system yet for the most
part to all of these questions they all
follow a similar pattern sooner or later
you'll run into something that really
ought to be implemented using an API not
provided by the reax primitives but
rather by a module for a certain
platform it's really important that we
don't lose the ability to take advantage
of these platforms specific api's when
we want to in order to do this we can
leverage another brilliant idea from
react native platform extensions we can
standardize on this concept of platform
based file extensions it's a relatively
simple concept but extremely powerful
javascript has a module system we create
it we create modules as files and import
them elsewhere our code base using the
import keyword the idea of platform
extensions is to extend this concept
slightly to introduced platform specific
implementations at the module level with
the introduction of specific file
extensions in this example we have the
fancy button module presumably a react
component the original implementation
works fine on all platforms so we just
use a dot jf file extension but maybe we
have a custom behavior or enhancement
that we want to make on an iOS device
only with some iOS specific
implementations so we create a fancy
button that iOS the j/s with the
enhanced implementation working on iOS
only but on all the other platforms will
all have the same interface as before so
now when we import a require fancy
button from any other file it will
automatically pull the correct
implementation depending on whichever
environment we're in sometimes we might
not be able to have this generic j/s
implementation that works on on
platforms so instead of having a Jas we
have a separate implementation for each
platform that we're wanting to support
this works well because we can isolate
the platform specific nature of our
application into single modules and
explode
as one common interface in more visual
terms if we imagine that we have this
dependency graph between all the modules
in our code base we might encounter a
situation where we want to do something
platform specific in a single module or
maybe it needs to be implemented
differently for each platform in that
case we split that one module by
platform and in each platform our
dependency graph deviates slightly but
remains consistent for the rest of the
codebase so let's work through a common
example of this a checkbox component
arguably a checkbox or a binary switch
is a pretty fundamental UI component and
so then you might think it should also
be a primitive on the other hand we can
implement this just fine as a component
built on top of the other primitives so
we go out and we create our react
checkbox library and in our package JSON
we depend on react and react primitives
and set our entry files and XJS we then
create our cross-platform implementation
of the check box using view touchable
stylesheet and any other primitives that
we need but on some platforms this might
not be good enough for instance on web
we probably wouldn't want to implement a
check box this way even though it might
function properly it won't be very
accessible and isn't compatible with
parent form elements so instead we
created check box web KS with an
implementation optimized specifically
for the web we still use react
primitives for things like styling but
we might actually render a standard HTML
check box input instead of a standard
touchable there would be a lot of
additional things we'd have to do to
create a real production quality check
box component to handle all the
different cases but the main point here
is that you're able to handle any
platform specific concerns in this file
then the last piece would be our main
entry file where we simply import the
check box and export it as our library's
main export this ensures that the proper
file gets resolved for each platform
there are huge ecosystems around react
and react native right now but they're
isolated from one another
converging on a set of primitives could
allow for these two communities to unite
by having an ecosystem of mature
cross-platform libraries and frameworks
built on top of primitives new and
emerging platforms are able to
immediately leverage them this does not
need to be limited to the only things
that that can be built with the react
primitives module and can extend into
far more interesting use cases by taking
advantage of this platform extension
technique as an example let's consider
charting charting is a very complex
problem and building interactive data
visualizations is complex no matter
which platform you do it on luckily a
couple of standards have emerged SVG a
web-based standard has native ios and
android support and react native
bindings for it has been built with all
of the SVG elements using platform
extensions we're able to expose a new
library with the same compatible
interface on web and native these are
there are also some charting libraries
on the web that target SVG and react
for example victory is a popular
charting library built by formidable
labs on on top of SVG in the web
interestingly formidable has also
released an almost identical native
version of the library that's built on
top of react native SVG again using the
platform extensions we're able to expose
a version of the library that depends on
react primitives SVG and is this fully
cross form fully platform compatible
across iOS Android and the web here's an
example of the chart that we're using in
our main app being displayed on android
iOS and the web the code that we write
to display this graph and render this
page is the exact same code for all
platforms taking this a bit further by
doing this for a handful of modules we
depend on we're able to run our entire
react native code base on the web
without changing much code we haven't
put anything using this on the web in
production yet but we're currently
exploring the practicality of such an
approach
oops sorry so as they get closer to the
end of this talk I'd like to ask a
simple question what comes next if we as
a community start building things in a
cross-platform and platform horrible way
what changes building things in this way
obviously solves a couple of big
problems and opens up some new
possibilities but it also creates new
problems that we didn't have before
for instance when you're working with
multiple platforms there's a lot more
cognitive overhead we need to be
building tooling to address these new
concerns for example editor plugins that
show which platforms a given file is
used on or perhaps which platforms it's
safe to use on a bunch of new es1
plugins could also be made to
effectively warn people about mistakes
they might be running into related to
this it's not just about new tooling
though are you coupling ourselves from
the underlying platform there's a whole
new set of possibilities that are
created when the effort to target a new
platform goes down by orders of
magnitude
I really enjoyed this quote from
Guillermo I'll react is such a good idea
that we will be spending the rest of the
decade continuing to explore its
implications and applications recently
this quote hit home for us at Airbnb
when we realized that we could leverage
sketch the application our designers use
as another target for our react code
bases we could actually use our
production react code and component
library in order to render directly into
sketch and make our designers workflow
more efficient we recently release react
Sketchup which does exactly that and
we're now exploring interesting ways we
can build we can build design tools the
levers our actual production component
implementations in order to make our
designers and engineers more productive
so the video you are seeing here is of a
sketch plug-in we've been working on
internally at Airbnb here will let me
leveraging react components that we're
initially targeting just react natives
and are now rendering a component picker
and previewer inside a webview on the
left hand side using react primitives
and react native web those components
are then dragged and dropped in the
sketch on the right hand side using
react primitives and react sketch out so
in other words we're using a single
react codebase rendering to two separate
platforms to create designs for a third
fourth and fifth platforms that we know
will be accurate because they're
leveraging the exact same code without
having our component code automatically
targeting all platforms doing something
like this would be completely
impractical so in addition to designing
new interesting new design tools by
having more and more of our code be
platform portable we're able to more
rapidly investigate newer platforms for
instance VR so I was losing a bit of a
silly example you would
you wouldn't you wouldn't actually want
to create a view our experience like
this so please don't do that but I think
it actually shows the power of a
portable code although VR has a wildly
different interaction model than than
web or native modal mobile there's still
a lot of potential for sharing smaller
components and UI elements that are
expected to be rendered as a
two-dimensional surface in VR whatever
the next class one may be I'm willing to
bet that someone will be using react to
render a UI in and wouldn't it be nice
if when you start to work on that
platform all of your existing code was
immediately compatible with it so I
wanted to give a special thanks to
Nicholas Gallagher for excellent work on
react native web and for collaborating
with me on react permitted I'd also like
to thank John Gould for the great work
that he's done on react sketch app and
for many long discussions around the
primitives the next time you're creating
a JavaScript library that depends on
react consider what additional
dependencies you're taking on both
implicit and explicit consider whether
or not it would be compatible with all
platforms
if you dependent on react primitives
instead of react native or react Dom
consider whether or not a simple
platform extension file would make it
work on more platforms than you
originally targeted together we have the
potential to create a true cross
platform ecosystem thank you
[Applause]